le ségur de la santé arrive au sénat en
première lecture sans grand enthousiasme
la proposition de loi a été adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture en décembre dernier après un
cheminement laborieux lors de l'examen
en commission des affaires sociales le
texte a été largement remanié
suppression de 10 articles sur 37
c'est le cas par exemple de l'article
1er qui a proposé la création d'une
profession médicale intermédiaire
suppression également de l'article qui
prévoyait l'intervention de bénévoles à
titre individuel dans les établissements
publics et privés de santé en dehors du
cadre associatif a été adopté en
commission un amendement qui tend à
garantir aux personnels paramédicaux une
meilleure représentation a par ailleurs
ont été précisés les dispositions qui
visent à lutter contre le recours abusif
à l'intérim médicale la précision
également sur les dispositions qui
élargissent les compétences des
sage-femmes le ségur de la santé a été
conclu on le rappelle en juillet dernier
après six mois de crise sanitaire et des
années de malaise dans les
établissements de santé
le ségur s'était d'abord matérialiser
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale adoptée en novembre à
des revalorisations salariales et des
investissements financiers en faveur des
établissements de santé y avait été
introduit